we've got more of our exclusive
conversation with first lady that's dr
jill biden yesterday she hosted a
ceremony at the white house to celebrate
the national teachers of the year for
2020 and 2021. so we sat down with her
and for the nation's top teachers before
the ceremony began juliana or tobay was
there
tabitha ross boy was there she's the one
that had on that cape that we were
talking about earlier john arthur was
there and so was chris dear these guys
were
sensational all of them dr biden as you
know is a teacher and like many other
educators she returned to the classroom
this fall too we asked them about their
experiences teaching during the pandemic
what does it mean to be a teacher in
2020 and 2021 you know because when i
was growing up i never thought of
teaching as a dangerous job i never
really even thought of as a stressful
job you know the teachers just seem to
do everything and have everything under
control what has this been like for you
all
it's been a scary time you know it's not
only
dangerous in terms of our health it's a
little bit precarious due to the
political situation we find ourselves in
where you have folks showing up at
school board meetings very upset and as
a teacher
and as a parent myself and as just a
member of my community i feel all these
mixed emotions because i see folks who
are upset i just want to
embrace them and say we're all in this
together were all of your schools hit
particularly hard by covid
my school would say particularly hard i
teach in new orleans and the delta
variant there really ravaged the the
city
in many ways it did show just how much a
community can come together and
persevere and we did see that
transition into the classroom as well we
saw a lot of students do everything that
they can during the pandemic to to stay
afloat how do we say to kids things are
going to be okay when you see parents
being so divided and so polarized about
something that seems to be very simple
as wearing a mask and what are your
thoughts as you look and you see parents
so divided about this issue who wants to
weigh in on that i'll weigh in i think
what teachers always do is we create
community within our classrooms and with
that comes collective wellness
i'm a better student if the person next
to me is learning and is having their
needs fulfilled and they know how to
advocate for their needs and i remember
when one little boy told me yeah i wear
my mask to keep my friends safe yeah so
when when you explain it to kids they
really do understand yeah
and they feel proud you know to be able
to do their part and i think that we
underestimate the importance of
acknowledging people doing their part
for me it's all about empathizing
without compromising you know
i had a student who was in my class last
year and she remained online even after
other students came back because she had
a father with pre-existing conditions
and just this past week he passed of
covid
and they did everything right and as
long as we can
humanize our conversations and our
dialogue as much as possible make sure
that we're bringing it back
to
reminding everyone this is a human issue
and we're just trying to take care of
people we're trying to teach our kids
trying to give them a brighter future
while also protecting them today and
i haven't had a parent yet who didn't
understand that yeah we should just be
fighting the virus not one another right
yes
this pandemic is it is is another thing
um that has made our job become
political somehow
in the way that much of our lives are
political i think education is
specifically subject
to the lawmakers that represent us right
the conditions of our workplace are
directly affected by decisions that
happen near the white house yeah and so
i think that
teachers get really frustrated when new
things pop up but i always say to them
we can handle this because we've always
been handling it you know what i say
your president understands because
there's a teacher in the white house yes
yes
you certainly have his ear yeah and what
what is your message to him
well i think i go home every single day
and tell him about my students about
teachers
about what we're facing in our
classrooms and the thing i love about
joe is he listens and he has listened
and look at the american rescue plan and
look at all the money he gave to schools
and
and for
social development and mental health
things that are really important to
teachers
and
i knew he would be a great education
president and that's one of the reasons
i was out there campaigning my heart out
well the teachers who are sitting here
what what frustrations do you have the
nature of teaching has somewhat changed
we are taking on many more roles than
than before there are students who need
you know mental health services or who
might
be lacking with their social emotional
development because of the pandemic and
we have to be
in some ways counselors i teach in a
school
in the most beautiful community shout
out meadowlark elementary
and
a lot of the kids did not have access to
the kinds of privileges that my children
will have access to
and and making sure that i was
not failing as a teacher at the same
time i was trying to not fail as a
father was
difficult to to go to bed with every
night and and it filled me with guilt
teacher guilt has been around since as
long as there have been teachers teacher
guilt teacher guilt that that feeling
like i'm not doing enough and we are
carrying all of the pre-pandemic weight
on our shoulders
and then all of this new stuff and
you know in a lot of ways we're stronger
we can bear more weight than we could
before dr biden what has frustrated you
during this time during this pandemic
well i guess you know not being able to
be in the classroom like everybody else
to see our students in person do you
ever come home and you say you know
it was a really tough day
dear honey what would you call him you
know
joe okay
this it's very difficult
it's very difficult well you can call
him joe yeah
it's very difficult it would be very
helpful if you would fill in the blank
make sure that we have broadband across
america so that all students have access
to technology
is that a game changer for nevada we
in the fall there was a public and
private organization that came together
to ensure every single child in our
state had a laptop and a wi-fi hotspot
clearly
we we we see the problems but clearly
all of you sitting here dr biden
included still love your jobs yeah you
still love teaching we do you know it's
it's the students i really love getting
in there every single day
planning these lessons and seeing those
light bulbs go off and seeing them
enjoying the classroom and
enjoying just being present as a teacher
i've always kind of seen that i can come
and be that warm friendly face to latino
families who are first generation like
me you know we can share stories that
are similar and we can really you know
come together on what do you need what
do you want from the school i love
teaching because i'm able to give
students confidence if i can give them
the confidence
to believe in themselves then i you know
i hopefully have given them a gift
children are the best people teaching is
the best job and there's no better way
to spend a day than in a classroom with
kids i love teaching because i can
empower not only my students but their
families and my community and i can make
a difference it's a job unlike any other
it is rewarding even when it's
challenging and it is totally worth
every moment of investment that you give
may we all feel that about our jobs we
thank you tabitha john chris
and juliana and of course dr biden
because it's clear their passion for the
job and their frustration for the job
too it was it was interesting when we
asked dr biden you know what do you say
to your husband i didn't know what the
nickname was i think it's more than joe
smith comes when i think it's more than
joe oh yeah but she said you know i call
him joe but she definitely has you know
ongoing and continued conversations
because she's just as frustrated as all
the teachers who are out there really
doing yeoman's work yeah yeah the first
time she definitely has an educator's
spirit yes you can tell very much
speaking of spirit i would just
encourage parents who might be dealing
with difficult issues surrounding
everything that we're dealing with i'm
just going to the school and asking the
teacher how are you doing because there
is a lot of weight on their shoulders
and just a simple question of truly
asking them how their spirit is that
goes a long way very good you know what
they all said that we can all teachers
students parents can all give each other
more grace
that's something that's missing these
days we're so busy
at each other we could all give each
other more grace because we're all
dealing with a lot no doubt about it